hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts biosafety risk
assessment fundamentals for clinical
laboratories presented by mike pant ella
PhD clinical professor at the University
of Iowa College of Public Health in
Christina mahalik of labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green
Q&A button located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to attain your
credits now please join me in wok
welcoming dr. kent ella i will now turn
the presentation over to him dr. pentola
um everyone
to our session everyone on risk
assessments I have nothing to disclose
on this first slide moving to the second
slide today's title is biosafety in risk
assessment many of you are learning how
to perform risk assessments in your
laboratories and I hope that this will
give you some further information my
first question for you is are you a risk
taker what is the risk is activity
yeah I've ever engaged it as you can see
from the photos and our leisure time
there are a lot of risky activities that
we do one of the things we don't want to
do is engage in risky activity in our
workplace we want our work environment
to be as safe as possible to protect
ourselves and our colleagues from
acquiring a lab acquired infection going
on to the second slide look at the
changes in laboratory safety during the
last 50 to 60 years the picture on the
right is from the archives is the state
hygienic laboratory in here in
Coralville Iowa around 1950 and as you
can see they're working in the
laboratory without any sleep protection
it was very common at that time to eat
and drink in the laboratory whereas
compare that to the slide on the left
where someone was working in a bsl-3
laboratory working inside a biosafety
cabinet using a popper the learning
gloves gown and the picture doesn't show
it but I know the person was wearing
shoe covers as well so in this slide on
the Left we're taking full precautions
at biosafety level 3 something that
would not have been done at the state
agenda clap in the 19
Fifty's moving on to the next slide this
is something that I put together called
the evolution of biosafety it's just an
interesting look back at biosafety in
the past 50 years there seems to being
three Sentinel events first back in the
early 1970s it was recognized that
laboratorians were at high risk for
hepatitis B virus infections as a result
there was a clamp down on eating and
drinking and smoking in the laboratory
and I know you can't imagine anyone ever
doing that but I assure you that I saw
it myself back in the 1970s there were
no federal requirements however there
were requirements from the College of
American Pathologists and ERDs and this
eventually became the norm that no one
was allowed to need a drink apply
cosmetics were smoked in the laboratory
there in 1987 OSHA
ensured the directive addressing
blood-borne pathogen exposure in the
laboratory and they made offering the
hepatitis B virus vaccine a requirement
and placed the term universal
precautions into our vocabulary this
later became standard precautions and
later the employer was required to offer
half of Acts at no charge to the
employee at starting in 1987 they didn't
have to offer it at no charge and then
2005 was another Sentinel event was with
the implementation of the Select agent
rule that place their strict
requirements on the handling of the
select agents all things organisms like
bacillus anthracis
crew Sela and others that are at high
risk of being used in a terrorism event
to 2011 aphl and CDC issued biosafety
competencies for laboratorians and in
2012 there was the another MMWR that was
the guidelines for safe work practices
in medical diagnostic laboratories
introduced so our objectives today are
to determine the reasons to perform a
risk assessment to discuss the biosafety
risk evaluation process provide you some
examples of risk assessments in the
microbiology lab and look at the role of
the risk assessment in the biosafety
program in children
I look at biosafety in the laboratory as
an infection control process and this
slide shows you from an infection
control perspective what's known as the
chain of infection how infections are
spread from the agent to a susceptible
host finding an entry site into the body
a means of spreading then exiting to the
body to a reservoir or on to another
individual anywhere along that point you
can break the chain of infection for
example if you vaccinate with up to
Titus B then hepatitis B virus being the
agent you vaccinate the susceptible host
you have broken the chain of infection
then because the person cannot acquire a
hepatitis B virus infection because they
have been vaccinated and have antibody
to prevent an infection so we look at
means of preventing infection along this
chain of infection looking at this slide
this gives you the typical portals of
entry of biological agents what are we
concerned about from a laboratory
perspective of acquiring an agent first
of all our mucous membranes
the eyes the nose the mouth we want to
protect our mucous membranes from splash
of splatter with a specimen or with an
agent we want to make sure that that's
not the portal of entry so using things
like splash guards are very effective
working inside the biosafety cabinet is
another effective mitigation strategy
another cause for concern is the
protection from aerosol so that we don't
breathe in a pathogen for example if
we're processing specimens for TB we
want to be working a biosafety cabinet
plus we want to be wearing a respirator
to be protect us from exposure to those
aerosols the gastrointestinal tract is
another means of entry into a body for a
biological agent in the laboratory we
want to protect you against splash
splatter and ingestion typically in the
lab for example we're working in the lab
you don't touch something and then put
your hands on your mouth so that you
might ingest what got on your hands
alright you're wearing gloves for
example so you make sure you don't touch
your mouth with your gloves another
means of entry is the skin so you
protect the skin from splash splatter
contact and puncture wounds so we've
done a lot in the laboratory to go to
needleless system so that we don't risk
a puncture wound so this shows you those
portals of entry that I was referring to
in the chain of infection slide prior to
going onto the next slide I'm asking the
question what is risk and I'll give you
the basic definition it's risk is the
likelihood of an undesirable event
happening that involves a specific
hazard or threat being asked
consequences
so you look at the following steps when
you're looking for risk so you're
looking at what work is occurring in the
laboratory to define the situation so if
you're working in the setup bench or
working with specimens and you're
defining the center situation of what
you're doing with those specimens you
define the risk with it within the
situation what can go wrong well you
could drop the specimen you could drop
the blood tube for example that is the
risk that can occur in what can go wrong
and you characterize the risk how likely
is it to happen what are the
consequences if the person does get an
infection so going through a risk
assessment process is asking yourself a
series of questions what is occurring
with the work what can go wrong how
likely is it to happen one of the
consequences is the person gets an
infection is there treatment is there
not treatment available so that is the
basic questions you ask in the risk
assessment and this slide shows you the
bio risk management process when we call
the ANP model it starts with the
assessment it looks at selection
mitigation and then performance making
sure the mitigation is used let's take
the example of looking at an assessment
of specimen processing everyone would
accept the fact that you need to wear
gloves when you're handling the
specimens because they could be
contaminated on the outside of the
specimen continuum you don't want that
contamination to get under your skin so
your mitigation step is wearing gloves
then performance of that requires
documenting the gloves that should be
worn training people that gloves need to
be worn in monitoring to make certain
that people continue to wear the gloves
so it's a three part stool as
demonstrated on the right
assessment mitigation in performance
now assessment can be defined as the
process of identifying the hazards and
evaluating the risks associated with
biological agents and toxins you need to
take into account the adequacy of any
existing controls mitigation factors to
decide whether or not the remaining risk
are acceptable now recognize that risks
are never going to be zero when working
in the laboratory the work itself
entails potential risk of exposure to
pathogens even though we're taking all
many precautions that weren't in that
1950s picture that I showed you there's
still risk that exists we can't bring it
down to zero but we can bring it to an
acceptable level so that we can do the
work that is required that we're there
to do for the benefit of the patient so
bringing this all together our risk
assessment then is the risk is the
probability that the health effect will
occur after an individual has been
exposed to a specified amount of hazard
that amount depending on the pathogen
and the person's own immune status the
risk assessment is that process of
gathering all the available information
and then that's followed by determining
the mitigation strategies that are
necessary to provide the protection and
again asking questions like what can go
wrong how likely is it what are the
consequences and I think the how likely
is it is a very important question
because we can't
always guarded against every single risk
that could occur we have to guard
against what's reasonable to expect to
occur so defining mitigation mitigations
are taking actions and control measures
that put they are put into place to
reduce or eliminate the risk associated
with working with biological agents and
toxins so the risk of working with TB is
different than the work with on risk of
working with staph aureus so you're
looking at the specific control measures
for the particular pathogens in the
particular work that is occurring in the
laboratory and you're looking at all of
those control measures and we're going
to talk about the control measures from
instrumentation to personal protective
equipment like clumps so if you're
looking at your overall miss risk
mitigation strategy about words here are
the lab practices if you want everyone
to be effective hand-washing good
hand-washing
you want there to be appropriate signage
in your laboratory that there's signs
posted no food or drink in the lab each
other you need to have good work flow
and that's what that floor plan on the
right describes you typically go from
clean to dirty areas in your work flow
above that are PPE
like gowns and gloves and respirators
and above that are biosafety cabinets
centrifuge containers with the seal
capped tubes and then your biosafety
plan which brings that all together you
really need to have a written biosafety
plan and your risk assessment helps you
to write that plate
now this slide gives you the
hierarchical controls the hierarchy of
control traffic so at the top is
physically remove the housing so just
don't do the work and we know that's not
an option we have patients need the work
that we do it's vital to help the
clinician make effective decisions use
antibiotics wisely and to prevent others
from getting an infection another way
would be substitution if you are in a
research lab you would typically use a
less pathogenic strain of the organism
another way our engineering controls
just isolate the people from the housing
and that's what the biosafety cabinet
helps you to do it helps you to isolate
the employee from the hazard of working
with the biological agent then there are
ministry of controls like your safety
plan your signage your other things in
place that you have in place then the
bottom tier is the PPE the personal
protective equipment like the gloves the
gowns the respirators but as you can see
from the left-hand side here the least
effective is the PPE as you go up the
engine for clinical labs engineering
controls are the best that we can do to
isolate people from the house or to
prevent transmission and when you're
thinking of the biosafety levels for a
laboratory like be us all one through
four that's essentially what's occurring
with engineering controls so when you're
thinking of your mitigation strategies
one of the first things you want to
think about is there are mitigation
through an engineering control or
doesn't need to be an administrative
control or lastly with a PPE be the most
effective control
so the implementation of the entire risk
bowel risk management system includes
evaluating and ensuring that the system
is working the way it was designed to
work and then you look at continually
improving the system so this is part of
your quality management system process
and you should think of biosafety as an
important component of quality
management systems so I'm asking here
the question why do a risk assessment so
you want to determine the relative level
of risk that each activity that you're
performing in the laboratory poses to
the staff performing that activity and
then this guides the risk mitigation
decision process now I wanted to drive
home the idea though that this is a
balancing act you're trying to balance
the risk against performing the work so
you have your practices that you're
going to implement to mitigate that risk
on the one side of the scale and on the
other side of the scale you're looking
at the performance of working and
accurate and efficient manner you know
that how important the work that we do
is we also have to balance that with
protecting ourselves from acquiring and
infection now as we do risk assessments
with this goal being the balancing we
also have to remember changes occur and
we should review our risk assessments at
least annually and we'll talk about
reviewing them when other changes occur
in our lab as well but at least annually
is a good thing to remember now when
you're performing a risk assessment I
like to put together what the work plan
is and the first thing that comes up on
the slide is engage everyone because
peep
doing the work our most intimate the
processes but someone has to listen to
put the process together in a risk
assessment so you start create a risk
assessment matrix for the agent the
protocol and staff susceptibility to
disease so this I'll show you some
example of matrixes that you can use to
look at your risk assessment in the
process then you identified the lab
procedure hazards through a protocol
driven risk assessment so I like to look
at each step in a protocol and determine
what is the risk of an exposure at this
step you know then ask the question what
mitigation can be put in place to
eliminate that risk or at least lower
that risk then of course determine the
appropriate biosafety level and risk
mitigation steps so biosafety level for
example if you're processing TB that
should be performed in a BSL 3 you
should consider what biosafety level
needs to go in BSL 3 work and what needs
to go and BSL two if you don't have a
BSL 3 then you may determine that you
may need to send that specimens to
another lab that will do that working at
bsl-3 as part of your biosafety plan
it's really important to evaluate staff
competency in utilization of safety
equipment we all know that after the
Ebola crisis one of the things that we
have identified that came out of it is
that people are not well trained in
putting on PPE
in taking off PPE the donning and
doffing processes this is one area
that's a good example that you can have
a competency written on another
competency may be you
zatia and will biosafety cabinet the CDC
recently put out through their train
system a really good training video on
using a biosafety cabinet this reviewing
that video could be part of a staff
member's annual competency so that they
are proficient at using a biosafety
cabinet and lastly review your
assessment with staff and management
everyone should be engaged in the
process in reviewing the assessment is
really an important part of that
engagement and my laboratories I've
signed off on the risk assessment after
they have been performed so that I could
be well-versed in what staff are
performing as the laboratory director
your next question is who's going to
perform this risk assessment well any
number of people could be doing this but
you want it to be somebody who's
knowledgeable has had practical
experience it has good problem-solving
skills it could be a team approach and
possibly a team approach is the best
because you have members of staff maybe
a ball safety officer or an experienced
individual is responsible for biosafety
and they get together and go through the
process of doing the risk assessment the
assessment needs to have knowledge of
the facility's safety principles modes
of transition the hazards and the
regulations that we're all under whether
they be local state or federal so
consequently with all the someone needs
to have knowledge of a team approach is
the most efficient when to perform that
risk assessment well it's best to
perform it before work begins you want
to be able to to have anticipate the
problems before people actually
experience problems so doing it before
work begins is best
but that's not always possible on
wherever there's AmeriCorps renovation
it's good to do their own assessment if
you have significant changes in
personnel turnover staff then redo your
risk assessment if there's an emerging
infectious agent that your lab is now
going to be receiving specimens for then
during a risk assessment is the
appropriate first step in addressing
that emerging agent and a boil is a good
example when laboratories heard that
there was the risk of Ebola patients
suspected of having Ebola being seen in
hospitals in the United States the best
approach from hospitals laboratory ins
would be to do a risk assessment if you
get new equipment do a risk assessment
even before you purchase that equipment
do the risk assessment to see what risks
there may be of acquiring an infection
from that piece of equipment and you
repeat the process when there are
changes made to reagents practices
employees or your facilities so there's
a lot of different types to consider
performing the risk assessment now
another time to consider is on this
slide changes and manufacturers or
suppliers if there's been a recent
accident my lab acquired infection or
maybe an exposure or theft or security
violation then consider doing your risk
assessment a national or regional change
in disease status a new disease is
endemic in your area et cetera then
performing the risk assessment is a
program so I broken this risk assessment
process into five parts I think it helps
us to look at the components what we
have to accomplish so the first would be
defined that situation so look at the
hazards that you're dealing with
defining the risk
and that's a lot to do with knowing what
the organisms are looking at the dose
response into the treatment format
cetera and characterized to risk looking
at the likelihood versus the
consequences
once the organism you're dealing with
means the host susceptible or not
looking at those tuned will go in more
depth on that and then after you
determine what your mitigation steps are
looking at your remaining risk and
determining if that's acceptable then
you go back and periodically we review
it so this is a five step process so in
this slide if you're looking at along
and continuance of time you look how
likely is the event to happen given that
occurrence what are the consequences so
these are the questions that you need to
be asking yourself likely here then is
the likelihood of acquiring an infection
after an exposure has occurred and it's
based on both the biological agents that
are involved and the work practices the
work performed in that law violet or the
consequences are was a person who's
exposed acquiring infection or will they
need to take post exposure antibiotics
or maybe they're supposed to exposure
vaccinations that might be involved to
any at risk individuals who are exposed
so we have likelihood and consequences
that we have to consider in the risk
assessment process give you an example
specimen receiving and we started
talking about this before what can go
wrong during a specimen receiving
process I gave you the example of the
outside of the container might be
contaminated with the pathogen just
looking at that container you may not be
able to see that it's visibly
contaminating so the question is how
likely is it what factors did
if you have to consider in assessing
that's likely well you know that this
specimens are collected at the patient's
bedside and they're sent to you
they could be spray splash spine or
blood on the outside of a blood culture
bottle that you're not going to be able
to see one of the consequences well
there could be a blood-borne pathogen
involved it could be another agent
involved those are things that you have
to consider and that's why we have
universal or standard precautions in
place because we want to consider any
blood or body fluids potentially
infectious and what mitigation measures
should you put into place to make the
risk of the specimen receiving
acceptable so we talked about wearing
gloves before decontaminating the
outside of the specimen containers
there's also a wise choice particularly
if it's blood culture bottles and you're
gonna put it into a blood culture
instrument decontaminate the outside
because somebody else is running out to
handle those blood culture bottles again
either when it's positive for growth or
later on when you have to discard the
negatives let's go into next light so I
like to start with the potential
pathogens involved I'm showing this
picture Ecoline of staph aureus that's
very common for a laboratory in their
encounter but down at the bottom left
hand corner is a picture of Frances Ella
to Loretta's several day old culture
growing in on chocolate longer and then
the right hand side is h5n1 avian
influenza
laughs throughout the country encounter
both of these organisms I know in Iowa
this past week I was told of the case of
Francis L O'Toole Aransas from a blood
culture and there were exposures in the
laboratory because the cultures were
handled on the open bench they did not
recognize it versus the potential for
Francis Ella to Laurentiis this this
happens in laboratories from time to
time and it's France
to sell to Lorentz's is common endemic
in your region of the country that's one
of the organisms that you have to
consider in your risk assessment process
as is a bee and influenza we've been
seeing this in different parts of the
country in past years and so it's
something you have to consider it has
potential so the first part of this
process is to estimate the risk based on
the pathogen the what's the infectious
steps some organisms have a very low
infection status
I'm sure you'll recall the organisms
like Mycobacterium tuberculosis is only
one organism can cause you to acquire
the illness
Shigella less than ten organisms so you
want to think of that and think of the
contagiousness of the organisms involved
how stable is that organism in the
environment does it readily die or it's
all organisms are susceptible to
temperature white pH desiccation
humanity you have to think of their
lifecycle their incubation period their
infectious period and how are they
transmitted so these are all to be
considered when you're looking at the
pathogens that you're encountering
so when you're encountering a new
emerging pathogen you sometimes don't
know all the answers so sometimes you
have to overcompensate because of the
lack of knowledge that you can on it but
for the most part you're dealing with
organisms that you know aren't familiar
with so when looking at pathogens I'd
like to fill out a matrix like this I
look at risk factors in the degree of
laboratory risk and look at the agent
considering pathogenicity virulence
infective dose and transmission and then
rate them from low moderate to high in
high so for example Salmonella
typhimurium is an organism that has
moderate pathogenicity causes a mild to
moderate disease
Mycobacterium tuberculosis is monitored
too high it causes serious disease and
but for the most part when we encounter
in this and the United States are
susceptible Mycobacterium tuberculosis
if we encountered multi drug resistant
or xdr-tb then it would be a different
situation we may move that to high
laboratory risk yeah
severe disease is herpes virus B being
an example of that infectious dose is
also listed here Vibrio cholera has a
very high infectious dose influenza
anywhere from ten to a six to a hundred
organism Francis although less than a
hundred organisms can cause disease and
how do you acquired and through contact
surfaces I've listed here and what
betting but that's not clinical apps but
is a direct contact or is it inhalation
so this is the type of matrix that you
could create if you're looking just at
pathogens another way to do this though
to approach this is by looking at a
protocol driven risk assessment so
you're looking at the lab activities to
drive the level of containment in the
mitigation that you need to implement or
on the high end there's a good example
is HIV amplification because if you're
going to be amplified the number of HIV
particles that's going to increase your
risk of exposure leads to increase in
the level of containment you would do
this in a biosafety level 3 laboratory
but most clinical labs don't do this
well if you ask the question now how do
laboratories get infected we have this
review from the clinical microbiology
reviews from school and all and from
1995 they looked and found that needle
Civics and sharp injuries were the top
reason for laboratory ins to get
infected this
followed by intention of arrow sauce and
then ingestion ocular and because it'll
splash your contact was in there as well
and then some rarer routes for formula
for laboratory it's fallen so in this
slide this is from that same article in
Table five
this looks at activities to generate in
ourselves
you have your inoculating a little
manipulation
so even streaking for isolation can
cause aerosolization if your pipetting
and depending on what they're just
transferring or your pipe propelling to
break something out by to mix of
microbial suspension that can cause
generation of aerosols then of course
needles from range manipulation and then
others like centrifugation vortex a VPN
a things like that all cause the risk of
aerosols all are steps that generate
aerosols
so if you're going to create a matrix to
look at protocol driven hazard
assessment then you're going to look at
the agent concentration the suspension
of volume generation of droplets
excedrin
under protocol hazards and you can rate
that to as well either or high and this
could be depending on the organisms that
you typically work with in your
laboratory so you look at things at low
risk as being less than a thousand
organisms fussing at one and now on
volume streaking smooth hog or standard
repetitive procedures and those are all
lower risk attributes on the higher side
so if you're dealing with agent really
high concentration great greater than 10
to the ninth greater the leader of fluid
if your flaming inoculating loop for
example through him change in complex
procedures that you might be falling
then those are at higher risk
so then you can also have to look at
those who would be susceptible to
disease so look at the potential for
exposure the individual susceptibility
the availability of vaccine or other
prophylaxis on antibiotic therapy and
available effective treatments so on the
low to moderate moderate to high and
high scale you have potential for
exposure visitors have very to the
laboratory have very low risk exposure
but if they were in the lab when you
were working with something like
Brucella then there would be a higher
risk for the dab exposure so then you
could go across but the most high being
the lab worker who handles the agent in
the laboratory having the highest risk
of exposure the individual
susceptibility goes the same way
somebody's been effectively immunized
they're not as they're at low risk but
it's the end if they're immuno confident
they're in a moderate to high risk but
if somebody's immunocompromised and this
could be for a number of reasons maybe
they're taking some treatment for a
disease for example that could pose them
to be immunocompromised then they're at
high risk let's look at the example of
Neisseria may enjoy this requires a
biosafety level 2 and bsl-3 practices
both working within a biosafety cabinet
protecting from aerosol and droplet the
cautions and why do we know this it's
because in the literature there are
multiple reports of lab acquired
infections with Neisseria meningitidis
from laboratory technologists in 12 out
of 32 of these lab acquired infections
were failing and it could be simple as
doing a catalase test on an open bench
that was the source of exposure may be
preparing
stain of a colony what we're worried
about and that's why I have the picture
of the plates here is working with the
amplified nursery managers there's not a
risk from working with the spinal fluid
before it's amplifying or receiving a
blood culture bottle but if you're
growing the organism in our culture
polymer you should always do your
subculture and Gram stain preparation
inside the biosafety cabinet because
you've amplified the organism so just to
give you some idea for one
epidemiologist calculate there are over
three thousand Iceland something senior
managers per year the attack estimated
attack risk should be is about thirteen
per 100,000 lab techs versus only 0.3
for 100,000 individual adults age 30 to
59 so that's the general population so
when you compare Latics
to general adult population lab techs
have a 13-time greater risk of acquiring
the infection than the general
population does for that age group this
slide shows you from sin Safari at all
the list of cases and they've put in red
boxes the fatalities these were
experienced laboratorians you can see
from the age of the patient for example
this patient being 46 years old this one
being 40 years old 45 50 to 65 years old
these were experienced laboratorians
who acquired these infections several
survived but there were a number of
fatalities so this is a large risk for
us in the laboratory
so if you were to fill out this matrix
then for no sería manager that's you
would say it's a high risk because
there's severe disease it's a very
lethal disease because there's been
deaths associated with it the infection
dose as well and the inhalation is
through air assaults so you want to work
inside a biosafety company to protect
yourself from getting this or exposure
to this organism to go on with your risk
assessment if you're working with a
plate you're going to have a really high
concentration of organisms or a blood
culture bottle and if you're generating
droplets and droplet nuclei you could do
so by just making a suspension for a
Gram stain on a bench top so but there
is a vaccine for Neisseria meningitidis
and that is very important to consider
here on this line now there is new
vaccine and you can all the serotypes
are covered but not everyone has
received the latest other vaccines so
it's well worthwhile to talk to your
occupational health department and see
if you can have your staff be offered
this newer vaccine where all the certain
types are covered now let's look at a
risk assessment that's protocol driven
and the example I have here is a
subculture of a positive blood culture
and listen what the potential hazards
are aerosol splash and splat I've
listened to what the controls could be
working inside of our safety cabinet and
wearing PPE so and I've listed out what
that PPE would be fluid resistant back
closing gown double gloves and 95
respirator goggles full facial so
you have everything listed here that the
individual should be using so then you
can also put in comments bring all the
necessary material onto the biosafety
cabinet before starting the work
do not enter and re-enter the biosafety
cabinet once specimen processing begins
so this tells you what your risks are
from performing ask activity what the
potential hazards are what your
mitigation there could be and what
training you need to do because you need
to be training your staff on how to
effectively use a biosafety cabinet so
they don't exposure themselves from
misusing that biosafety cabinet here's a
second example
this is Mycobacterium tuberculosis
performing susceptibility testing so
you've grown up the organism and now
you're going to inoculate beat the broth
for susceptibility testing and here
again your potential hazards are aerosol
generation you could spill it could leak
etc people are exposed while
manipulating the solid culture in the
tubes so there's moderate risk and there
is risk from exposure to the liquid
culture that's a higher risk so you have
your PPE listed again working in a bsl-3
laboratory or some people use bsl-3
precautions while working in a bay on
assault tubes they don't have that
available to them that can be considered
as well all culture manipulations
performed inside a biosafety cabinet on
disinfectants soap pads so if you get
any splash or splatter it drops on those
pads and this in fact it will kill it
and then you dispose of inoculating
loops and transfer pipettes etc either
rich and container containing
disinfectant and you keep that container
inside your biosafety cabinet so your
hands aren't going in and out with your
inoculate whoops so this sort of
summarizes what I was talking about
before with likelihood eating
consequences so if you look at
increasing likelihood
in increasing consequences when your
likelihood is low in your consequences
well then you have a very safe consider
situation but if it's moderate but high
then you have to consider your
mitigation steps so for a glucose test
you see there is a broken tube of blood
in the centrifuge well where would you
put the likelihood in the consequences
here it's just a blood glucose test
there's no infectious process going on
here that you know so but there could be
a blow of our pathogen issue so of
course you have to be concerned of that
but hopefully everybody in your
laboratory has received hepatitis B
virus but there's hepatitis C and HIV to
be concerned as well so there are
consequences associated if you have on
this example a positive TB [ __ ] tube
breaks on removal wow that's a very high
likelihood of exposure to air assaults
and also very moderate to high
consequences because that could be a
multi drug-resistant TB you don't know
at this point so here's another
situation an owner wants a pet back
after it's being tested for rabies well
there's no treatment for rabies and once
something's been in the rabies
laboratory
it could be cross contaminated from
other positive rabies samples so high
likelihood a high consequences so you
naturally would not allow that pet to
leave that laboratory I'm
host factors to consider before I'd like
to cover this a little bit more depth on
pregnancy is considered a host factor
that puts you at greater risk of
acquiring infection there are
medications that we commonly take that
could put us at a higher risk of
acquiring an infection breaks in the
skin using an inhaler in the laboratory
for example like we put you at higher
risk of infection someone who is
extremely tired and typifying in this
bottom right and picture could put you
at high risk of acquiring the infection
it's important to consider what vaccines
you're going to offer in your laboratory
based on what tests that you're doing
what protocols you perform hepatitis B
of course is required to bozhe a very
good idea to have tetanus and diphtheria
offered influenza on an annual basis
should be offered and encouraged
pneumococcal vaccine might be considered
hepatitis A measles mumps rubella
varicella and for your microbiology
staff meningococcal vaccine is
recommended if you do rabies testing or
anthrax work you would consider those as
well you want to write this into your
occupational health sop you want to have
a process for reporting events and
illnesses events meaning incidents
exposure incidents how are you going to
respond to potential exposure events
staff need to want to know exactly what
is expected of them if they get exposed
so that they will take the steps as
quickly as possible how do you respond
to respiratory illness and laboratory
workers do you worry that it could have
been laboratory inquire what are your
response for illness with your post
exposure prophylaxis do you do fever and
hwachun is do what occurs if somebody
goes on a bike therapy etc
what if somebody needs laboratory
testing and how do you decide when the
person is ready to return to work all
these should be in your SOP so at a
minimum your practices should include
offering empathetic B immunization in
other immunizations as available and
based on the expected work areas such as
the Neisseria meningitidis vaccine for
those who work in microbiology and then
you want an ongoing evaluation if in the
respirator program
somebody's enrolled and wearing a
respirator they need to have an
evaluation at least annually now this
final slide is titled are you making
these risk assessment blunders and this
is from David can't I found that at this
link below and these are the blunders
that he's referring to not doing a risk
assessment not properly identifying your
hazards not creating and they are
creating an inadequate risk assessment
now serving safety practices because you
have a document without doing the
training and your staff and putting
things and watching for compliance with
these activities not involving your
employees all the staff need to know
what's expected of them and why it's
expected of them and another blunder is
assessing risk generically not looking
at your specific workplace you have to
craft your risk assessment process for
your particular work environment that's
my last slide I'll turn it back over to
Christina
thank you doctor can tell look for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green at Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for let's
get started and our first question asks
does my my lab does not allow the use of
cell phones in the lab or cell phones of
biosafety risk are definitely a
biosafety when you bring a cell phone
into the laboratory you risk
contaminating that cell phone with what
you're working with in the laboratory
and you also need to consider where
you're taking that cell phone afterwards
I know people who use cell phones to
look up recipes while they're cooking
dinner so if you have your laboratory in
the lab wall and your cell phone in the
lab all day and then you go home and use
your laboratory on your cell phone while
cooking dinner you risk contaminating
your food with what you've worked with
if you've worked on the entire bench
that day it's not a good idea if there's
an ongoing outbreak with Salmonella
because people taking things from the
laboratory out of the laboratory into
where they're eating so you definitely
need to be concerned about cell phones
and restricting cell phone use in the
laboratory it's a very wise thing for a
laboratory to do do we have any more
questions
I'll hold on I'm told we have just a
little technical problem so hold on for
our resolution is technical thank you so
much okay our next question of the day
this question asks our lab is getting a
maldita are these biosafety risks risks
that we should consider it's becoming
much more common in laboratories today
it's great instrument as I'm always off
I think it's excellent but you also have
to consider that the process is in use
with a lollipop for example you're going
to spotting direct spotting you're not
going to be killing the organism so
consequently you have to be concerned
one if that's a highly pathogenic
organism that you're using maybe you
want to use the tube method to kill it
kill the organism another thing you need
to consider is the other processes don't
disappear like the need for Gram stain
take the Frances lo2 Lorentz's example
for the organism as an example if you
were directly to go from that plate to
the multi shot a that organism isn't in
the database for more than Josh at this
time and B you might get a
misidentification you all worked with
our open bench so the processes that you
need to be aware of the central lab
protocols that are put forth by a s
still are in place and you still need to
take all those same precautions I'm
using a biosafety cabinet to do the Gram
stain on suspected Frances only two
emergencies so your process is still
have to account for those risks so when
you get them all the talk you should
consider your processes and do a risk
assessment for that instrument before
you put it to working in the laboratory
are there any further questions yes
thank you
actually there is this will be the last
question of the day since we're running
tight on time do you have do some labs
include biosafety competencies in the
annual conference competency assessment
program it's a really good idea just
like we have competencies for using
instruments or performing tests we
should have competencies for biosafety
as well competency for using a biosafety
cabinet competencies for donning and
doffing PPE competencies for spill
cleanup those are just three examples of
things that you could do in your
laboratory to incorporate competencies
into your cup biosafety into your
competency program back to you Christina
I would like to once again thank dr.
pentamer for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
this educational webcast possible before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February of
2018
you will be emailed you will be emailed
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live events
that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you here again soon at lab roads goodbye